nightclubs in ireland are to close over
christmas and new year and the
government is to bring back tighter
restrictions for pubs and bars the move
is expected to add to pressure on boris
johnson to consider changing his
position on christmas celebrations in
the uk
it's because of the new omicron covid
variant which is still providing more
questions than answers for scientists
tonight
but new analysis from the uk health
security agency has started to fill in
some of the gaps in our knowledge we'll
have more on that shortly but first here
are the changes announced by the irish
prime minister miguel martin
let's take a look at those new
restrictions nightclubs will be closed
and there'll be strict social distancing
measures put in place in bars and
restaurants a maximum of six adults will
be allowed at a table and there will be
a ban on multiple tables being booked
only three households will be able to
gather in one private dwelling although
mr martin acknowledged there'll be a
need for flexibility
there'll be a maximum of fifty percent
capacity at entertainment cultural and
sporting events and people attending
those must be seated
and covered passes will be extended to
gyms leisure centers hotel bars and
restaurants all restrictions will be in
place from tuesday until the 9th of
january
at every stage of this awful covert
journey
as a country and as a people we have
trusted the science and we have done our
best
we haven't always got it right and there
have been times of great frustration
but
every time we have faced a new challenge
we have pulled together as a nation and
done what was needed
i'm asking all us all to do that again
further study and examination in the
weeks ahead may discover that omicron
does not represent a more deadly threat
and if that is the case it will come as
a great relief to us all
but we simply cannot take that risk with
people's lives and health
this guy's david blevins joins us now
from belfast and david do we know what
exactly has preempted this move
well we had some very sobering words
indeed from the irish prime minister
anti-ship mehol martin in his address to
the nation tonight confirming that there
are two primary causes of concern for
the irish government the unknown level
of threat posed by the new south african
variant even though there has only been
one case of it detected on the island of
ireland ireland so far but also the
potential for a surge in cases as a
result of increased socializing during
the christmas period it's understood the
national public health emergency team
gave the government a very stark warning
earlier that ireland could see up to 15
000 cases of covert after christmas if
it doesn't do something now to curb
social interaction during the festive
period so the government has effectively
turned back the clock to october 22nd by
closing night clubs reimposing
restrictions on their hospitality sector
demanding covert passports for gyms and
leisure centers and
reducing the number of households that
can gather together of course this comes
just a few days after the government
announced that everyone arriving in
ireland would require a negative pcr or
antigen test now you can imagine the
level of devastation there is across the
hospitality industry as we approach
christmas and that happening for the
second year in a row the government's
attempting to reassure them that their
jobs and businesses will be safe by
providing some level of financial
security but let me say this if you're
struck by the contrast between what's
happening in the uk and what's happening
for its closest neighbor do bear in mind
that one part of the uk northern ireland
shares a land border with the republic
of ireland and that creates the bizarre
scenario where you could have a pub in
the republic imposing restrictions in
another one half a mile away effectively
operating as normal